i want to thank
you for the excuse to wear a jacket and
tie
okay you can start now well good morning
everybody we have uh
we have panelists and we have attendees
and this is the first uh
remote meeting of science technology and
energy and
uh and i want to welcome everybody uh
both the members and the attendees
um i do have a script that i'm going to
read to uh
illustrate that we are in compliance
with all requirements
for conducting business as a legislative
committee of the general court
and i will do that now this is thursday
tuesday thursday december 3rd 10 am as
chair of the science technology and
energy committee i find that due to the
state of emergency declared by the
governor
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic and
in accordance with the governor's
emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04 this
public body is authorized to meet
electronically
please note that there is no physical
location to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
which was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order
however in accordance with the order i
am confirming that we are
a providing public access to the meeting
by telephone
with additional access possibilities by
video or other electronic means
we are utilizing zoom for this
electronic meeting
all members of committee and select
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through this platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by clicking on the following website
address https
slash slash zoom dot u s slash
j 9 j
9 8 3 6 nine three nine
two five four zero
be a quiz on that we're dialing one of
the following phone numbers
one three one two six two six
six nine six seven nine nine six two
six seven six seven nine nine or one
nine
two nine two oh five six o nine nine
e we are providing notice of the
necessary information for
assessing the meaning we previously gave
notice to the public of the necessary
information for accessing the meeting
including how to access
by the the meeting by using zoom or
telephonically
the information is in the current house
calendar c
providing a mechanism for the public to
alert the public body
during the meeting if there are problems
with access if anyone has a problem
please call 271 3600-271-3600
or me email at hcs for house committee
services hcs
ledge dot state dot nh dot us
d adjourning the meeting if the public
is unable to access the meeting
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting with us
joel anderson is the meeting host
additional staff are providing support
our gen 4 and brad greenland
this is a work session on bills referred
to the to this committee for interim
study
an executive session will follow copies
of the interim study have been posted on
the main page of the general court
website
under the heading remote meetings please
note that all votes
that are taken during the meeting shall
be done by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call for attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting
which is required under the right to
know law and obviously i'm
bob backus and i'm at the meeting and i
have no one in the room with me
um who would like to go next
shall i just go down the road how about
leah how about you just call up
thanks very much yeah just go down the
road call that would be that would be
good representative moffatt
i'm present and there's no one in the
room with me representative callie pitts
all right um this is john mann i'm
present and no one's in the room with me
representative oxnam i'm present and no
one is in the room with me
[Music]
vincent
i believe he is not present
representative bulge i'm present
and no one is in the room with me
representative mcgee
i'm present and there's no one in the
don't see her here
representative saunderson i'm present
and no one is in the room with me
representative wells i'm present and no
one is in the room with me
representative harrington
i'm present and no one's in the house
with me
i don't see her here
representative boasts uh
his absence uh representative
aldridge
don't see representative aldridge
representative president home alone
that completes the roll call okay
thank you very much representative
oxenham
we do also have attendees with us i see
according to my
item here at 21 attendees if attendees
want to
raise their hands i will attempt to call
on them after we have
completed the discussion by committee
members and i guess
at this time we'll move to the business
to this meeting which is to uh
take a committee position on the four
bills that were sent back to us for
interim study
and we'll just take them up in the order
in which they appeared in the calendar
the first one is a house bill 1262
relative to the purchase of output of
limited electrical energy producers
uh do we have anybody that would like to
speak to this bill and i remind
everybody as we all know i guess that
the issue is simply whether there shall
be
a recommendation for further legislative
action on this issue
or not would anybody like to speak to
this
would you like to entertain a motion at
this time mr chairman
well we are gonna we're gonna we're
gonna do that when we move to the
executive
session and we're not quite there yet
but
that would be an order very soon it
looks like
uh i see no hands raised unless i'm
mistaken
for either our panelists or our
attendees
so that uh that goes quickly
um the next one is house bill
1370. wrote to
relative to baseload renewable
generation credits for biomass
energy facilities is there any
discussion on this on the part of the
panelists
if so please raise mike can you hear me
bob
mike i can hear you yes
that this is just another subsidy for
the biomass um obviously we're opposed
to going
any further with this so okay thank you
you beat that into the ground okay
all right anybody else wish to discuss
this
yeah i'd like to speak on it um since
the
the you know the subsidies had gone away
on some of them
we're down to just two plants now
running and one will be closing soon and
the big problem we're having
with our forest if we're not getting
temper management in the last four or
five months
it's dropped off incredibly um a 30-ton
truck of chips went for a thousand
dollars for 30 ton
now it's going for 125 dollars
so they've abandoned doing their
cleaning and the
work is being done i think we have to
look at some kind of future legislation
i don't know if this feels right
i don't i know that we have to look at
it though
okay i'd like to agree with troy on that
i think that it's more complex than just
offer on
as far as being a manufacturing industry
in the state and how it affects the
economy
so i am i would propose that we do try
and
figure out what is the right answer
because i'm i'm not sure that this um
pulling the plug the way that we have is
an appropriate response with the economy
having issues as it is so i i would be
for
bringing it back and making a
recommendation to take it forward
okay mr chairman could i
make a suggestion that um committee
members that they can
raise their virtual hands so and that
way that they're that you can keep it
track of who raised their hands in what
order
so yes thank you joel i was going to
mention that
if you go into the the the icon for
panelists
you will participants i should say you
will see the raise hand
icon there it's on my computer it's on
the lower right side of that
panel so but do use that i'll be able to
see it and recognize you and that'll
make a
perhaps more orderly discussion is there
anybody who would
now would like to uh to speak further on
it and raise a hand on it i'm
currently not seeing anybody they have
visible hands of
jackie callie pitts and ken wells
and yes and raised too okay
mr chairman one of these raised him but
i'll go to you first uh representative
sampson
go right ahead yeah thank you remus mr
chairman uh
i'd like to agree with representative uh
murder and representative mcgee
um i'm not i'm not uh saying that this
bill as is
is worth pursuing but something like
this is worth pursuing
i know there are issues around the
emissions from
biomass plants i think those can be
managed
on the other hand this is an in-state
renewable energy resource
that we have it's not an out-of-state
dependency we have and we should not
give this up without a fight
um also it has as we know large economic
impacts in our state
and for jobs and uh the economy
again we shouldn't give that up so
easily we should find a way of making
this work
uh this provides us a little extra
energy independence
and resilience it provides environmental
benefits for our forests it provides uh
environmental benefits for the tourism
industry
uh i think it would be foolish for us to
give something like this up when we have
such a well-managed forest in new
hampshire
possibly because we have a biomass
industry so i would
support recommending legislation in the
future
okay mr chair i see
representative wells yes thank you i
agree with uh uh representative
samsich's uh
assessment on this this is something
that we shouldn't uh give up easily i
understand that there are problems
uh that we need to address about the
pollution from biomass
but um economically there are 3.3
million tons of wood
harvested every year in new hampshire
and only about 1 million tons
is a high-grade timber
the rest of it is is low-grade uh wood
which uh is
sold for a paper pulp or for energy
biomass
and um the forest product industry
employs about 6 200 individuals in the
state
and produces an annual payroll of 242
million dollars
uh so this is uh not only is it an
important renewable energy source that's
produced in state
but what it does for our economy is
important and so i think that that
we should bring this bill forward for
further consideration and
and see if we can work out some of the
uh the difficulties um
surrounding the uh biomass pollution
thank you representative wales but just
remember it won't be this bill it'll be
a new bill
right would be doing okay representative
platten you have your hand raised i had
my hand up whoa
uh well you don't i i'll get to you yeah
yeah okay i understand
all right yes this is another
government attempt to reach into the
pockets of ratepayers
to support a favorite technology totally
against all of these
well she may have stepped out for a
minute representative thomas
yes thank you mr chair um
my only concern is the
management of our forest
the way this bill does it is
unacceptable to me
i would be interested in some action
that would cause our forest to be
properly managed but it should not be on
the backs of rate payers or anything
having to do with your electric bills
so perhaps in the future we can find
some way of supporting our cars
which to me is the most important issue
okay
thank you representative callie pitts
this vote has no uh what we do our vote
has no
no bearing on anything i think i've been
working for years
to keep the forest industry alive and we
thought
biomass was the next best thing for god
when we got rid of coal
so i think that we need to work on it
and whoever wants to can work on that
and that goes for any committee or
anybody else
and i i think we have to
if we don't have any time but i think we
we should
informally discuss this between now
and the next filing period what we're
going to do and put a placeholder in
there
because we just can't let this industry
go belly up it's not just the industry
it's all the peripheral industries
around it
and this is not the time to put a nail
in the coffin
of an industry okay
um anybody else want to
participate in this discussion i don't
see any hands raised
let me look at the attendee list and
make sure i haven't missed anybody there
no i guess not okay
and if not that's if there's no further
discussion on
uh house bill 1370 we can go on to
house bill 1402 established procedures
for municipal
host uh customer generators of
electrical energy
that may be people joining or on not
joining that may be what that means i
don't know
yeah bob is there any necessity to take
these in numerical order
uh we have thirteen seventy
we just finished that one yeah that was
what we just discussed
sorry okay thank you
uh and even the any of the panelists
that is the members of the committee
have anything they wish to say to the to
the committee about this
i'm looking to see if we have any raised
or on the phone i guess uh i'm not
seeing anything on this
uh representative mcgee i believe has
her hand up no she does i'm sorry
thank you um we just have to get used to
this little
panelist box using the
that's what he was saying before jackie
when he wasn't recognizing your hand is
to use the
the hand raise in the box um
yeah i i think there were some good
pieces um
in this in the vehicle um
and so i would be in favor of working on
this
um maybe across the maybe you know
members from both sides on it to try and
figure out what we could do
um to try and make it more comprehensive
than it initially was designed
um but also still targeted
so i i actually think there's something
there so i think maybe
not this bill itself but a version of
thank you i'm just going to say i don't
have a hand anywhere
would you like that represent kelly
pitts i don't know
um i don't have sure it's do you have a
the
the participants panel participants
panel
okay and if you go down to the the uh
very bottom
of that panel okay that's where it is
if you see it there yeah i see
it says raise hands there you go it
worked it worked okay
all right i just didn't know where to
find it because i didn't see any cans
hanging
on here okay good
we got you up to date here good to know
uh looking at the participant list i'm
not seeing i don't think anybody
on the i mean the attendees list i don't
think i'm seeing anything there either
i believe representative mann just
raised his hand okay
i don't have much to say but i just
think this is an important subject and
we should
submit it for consideration
all right thank you thank you all
any any further any further comments or
questions from anybody either on the
panel side of the attendee side
joel i'm not seeing any unless you see
something i'm gonna move on
okay i don't see anything and the next
one is house bill 1429
relative to integrated distribution
plans of electric utilities
and again i am ready to uh uh recognize
anybody on the
on the committee for a comment on this
if there is one
let's see i see representative mcgee
that's me um i actually sponsored this
uh with the office of the consumer
advocate
and we had a discussion uh that if there
is anything more that is going to be
done on this topic or others that it
will be a separate bill so we can just
recommend that this one go okay
yeah it wasn't needed yep all right
anything further from the members of the
committee or any attendee
uh this is mike harrington i just say i
agree with what representative mcgee
just said
thank you representative harrington uh
anything further
okay unless there is anything else
anybody wants to bring up uh for
purposes of this work session and this
would be of course
i don't think pretty likely because we
discussed the four bills into the
subject of this work session
but other than that i think i can now uh
declare that the
work session portion of this committee
meeting uh
to be uh to be concluded
and we can move into our executive
session
so i'm now opening the executive session
oh wait a minute do i see a hand raise
from representative oxendian
a very late entry i'm i'm noting at the
bottom of my form for the subcommittee
work session that it's
asking me to fill out boxes on the
recommendation
as to whether or not during the work
session
we came up with a motion either to
recommend
for future legislation or not recommend
for future legislation
is that necessary joe or can we simply
proceed
you can just proceed it's not required
very much
okay all right then we will proceed
uh let's see we have the first one is
house bill
1262 and i believe we are expecting a
motion on that
let's see who's going to be making the
that would be from me i moved in hb
1262 relative to the purchase of output
of limited electrical energy producers
be recommended for future legislation
the bill promotes a number of positive
goals and the governor gave it his
strong support several utility
representatives indicated that it needed
further refinement to make it viable
and this can be achieved by the sponsors
in a new bill
so the motion is recommended for future
legislation is there a second from
anybody
i would second that thank you motions
made and seconded
uh there can be discussion although of
course we've had the discussion i would
think uh pretty much in the uh
in the work session does anybody have
any further discussion that they would
like to present at this time
i see none okay and with that i guess uh
our able clerk represent oxnam can
proceed to call the role
on this motion representative moffatt
yes representative callie pitts
yes representative mann
yes representative oxnam
yes representative samsic
yes representative bulge
yes representative mcgee
yes representative saunderson
yes representative wells
yes representative carrington
yes representative merner
yes representative ober
no representative play
yes
oh and uh you didn't call in the chair
but i vote yes
oh excuse me that's okay representative
backus is recorded as a yes that would
be 14
yes votes and one no vote
and the non-voting i guess is the sum of
those who are not present
what's the total vote i'm sorry fourteen
one five thank you
okay all right now we're ready for
house bill 1370 relative to baseload
renewable energy credits for biomass
and who is going to be presenting a
motion on that please i'd like to
move uh that we uh recommend
uh house bill 1370 for uh further
legislation
okay moved by representative wells
seconded by representative jackie callie
pitts
any further discussion seeing none i
again i call upon our clerk to call a
roll
representative moffitt yes
representative callie pitts
yes representative mann yes
representative oxenous yes
representative samsic
yes representative bulge
yes representative mcgee yes
representative saunderson yes
representative wells yes
representative harrington no
[Music]
that would be 10 yes four no and
five and once again the chairman also
votes yes
i'm sorry this have you at the top but
you're supposed to be called last and
i'm sorry
that's okay that's no problem
so the total is again uh well that would
change it to 11
4 5 11 in favor
four opposed five not voting
and finally and i guess you know folks
think about this this is
probably our last vote as a committee in
this term here
something extraordinary happens this may
well be it and it's on house bill
1429 relative to the integrated
i believe we did yes bob we have a third
bill
oh did i skip 1402 1402
i'm sorry you're exactly right 1402.
strike all that from the record let's go
ahead this is next to last vote of the
committee
1402 establishing procedures for
municipal and
host customer generators of electrical
energy and
i i'm going to make a motion to
recommend that we we uh provide further
legislation on it
okay the motion is to provide further
legislation is there a second for that
motion
second second representative is
recognized for a second
okay moved by representative mcgee
seconded by representative samsich
any discussion on this before we call a
roll
seeing none the clerk will call a roll
representative moffat yes
representative callie pitts yes
oxenam
i'm i'm sorry i lost my place again uh
yes representative samsic yes
representative bulge yes
representative mcgee yes representative
saunderson yes representative wells
yes representative harrington
yes i'm i'm sorry i could not hear that
vote yes
was that a yes yes yes it was a yes
yes thank you uh representative
yes representative merner
yes representative ober
yes representative plett
yes and the chair
6 here 10 12 14. that would be 15
yes no no's
okay and now we're down to the last vote
uh
house bill 1429 relative to integrated
distribution plans of electric utilities
okay and i believe representative mcgee
is going to move that one
yes i'm just going to move for a
recommendation of no further legislation
all right and is there a second i'll
second it
okay thank you who who was that
representative roxanne
uh that was representative callie pitts
i believe okay
thank you representative kelly pitts
moved and seconded that the
recommendation be no further legislative
action in this regard
are we ready for the uh roll call
anybody got anything they want to add
before we move to the roll call seeing
no hands raised i'll ask our evil clerk
to call the rolls
representative moffatt yes
representative kelly pitts
i give you my best new york yeah
representative mann yes representative
oxenom yes representative samsich
yes representative bulge yes
representative mcgee yes representative
saunderson
yes representative wells yes
representative thomas
yes thank thomas yeah
yeah representative mirner yes
representative ober yes representative
plett
yes and our noble chair representative
backus
15 yes no no's
and five not voting
okay mr chairman yes
yeah this is mike harrington i just
wanted to say a quick thing here i
realized that you and howard are leaving
i just wanted to say
how much we appreciate all the hard work
you've put in over the last few years
and we wish you the best of luck in the
future and we i'm sure we'll run into
you someplace else but uh
good luck and thank you well thank you
very much and we're going to have a
little bit of a
little bit of a gathering here on the
zoom thing once we close this executive
session
representative harrington so you jumped
the gun a little bit but it's very
welcome
okay uh very glad to have you do that uh
representative plett did you have
something you wanted to say before we
close the executive session
not muted i mean you're you're muted you
need to unmute
uh close the executive session and then
uh call on me please
i will do that sir i'm all right mr
chair mr
just one thing that is um just a
reminder that um the people who made the
motion
for the whatever recommendation the
committee approved
they need to make write up a statement
and send it in to you
so however i don't think there's a big
time urgency on that i guess it'll be in
the calendar november is that right
right it may be good to do it sooner
rather than later of course now it's
usually good to do things sooner rather
than later
well they're fresh in your mind so by
all means i would hope our
four moving members would would get that
in to me and to
joel
as reasonably as soon as it's convenient
for you and thank you for agreeing to do
this
uh there are no minority statements
attached to these so that that'll be it
uh anything else before i again
declare that the chair
representative thomas do you have your
hand up yes i do thank you mr chair um
strictly for the record it's a minor
point but
uh when the final vote count was read
the statement was made that five were
not voting
uh that's incorrect their five people
were not present
of course if you were president you had
to vote so just
as a matter of um you know typicality
yeah
we now have a form with nv is the
the column and i was instructed that
that's
not voting but thank you for the uh
the suggestion always happy to have the
former clerk
uh correct me in my
anything further to come before the
committee before we conclude this
executive session
seeing nothing i guess joel you can
stop the recording and i'll declare this
executive session now
concluded thank you all for
participating in being president on our
first and
maybe maybe we dare hope only a
remote committee meeting as this
committee goes forward in the next term
okay the i don't have my big gavel
there you go the executive services